[Música]
en Estados Unidos su nombre de 22 años
mató a cinco personas e hirió a 25 en un
club lgbt en Colorado en la noche de la
memoria trans el agresor que perpetró el
ataque con un rifle estaba bajo custodia
policial
tres días de luto nacional en Argentina
por la muerte de Eve de bonafini
presidenta de la asociación Madres de
Plaza de Mayo bonafini es un símbolo de
la lucha contra la dictadura de Videla y
de la defensa de los Derechos Humanos
este lunes el gobierno de Colombia y la
guerrilla del eln retoman los diálogos
de paz suspendidos bajo la presidencia
de Iván Duque la primera fase será de 20
días y tendrá lugar en la capital de
Venezuela Caracas
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más relevantes
del continente americano soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos en Estados Unidos porque el
sábado por la noche un hombre de 22 años
mató a cinco personas e hirió a otras 25
en un bar lgbt y cumas en Colorado
Springs el agresor que se encuentra bajo
custodia policial abrió fuego con un
rifle en el club q donde se conmemoraba
la noche de la memoria trans
Precisamente en recuerdo de las personas
trans asesinadas en ataques violentos la
policía y el FBI investigan el incidente
que el club calificó de crimen de odio
[Música]
Era una noche festiva en el club q Un
refugio para la comunidad lgbt de
Colorado Springs estaban conmemorando el
20 de noviembre Día del Recuerdo
transgénero cuando cada año se hace un
homenaje a las personas trans asesinadas
en plena fiesta irrumpió una persona
armada y disparó
cuando salí había cuerpos en el piso
había vidrios rotos vasos rotos gente
llorando
[Aplausos]
el sospechoso fue identificado como
Anderson lealdrick de 22 años dos
personas lo redujeron y evitaron que
pudiera continuar matando el club q los
llamó héroes en un comunicado y así lo
vivió uno de sus camareros
mi primer pensamiento en lo que no puedo
dejar de pensar es en las imágenes de la
noche de los cuerpos de la sangre de los
vidrios rotos de la carnicería y los
escombros y ver un lugar seguro
convertido en una zona de guerra
el ataque más mortal después del 11 de
septiembre de 2021 fue en 2016 en una
discoteca lgbti de Orlando cuando 49
personas fueron asesinadas según
estadísticas oficiales Estados Unidos
vive un resurgimiento de ataques contra
personas transgénero el presidente Joe
biden se solidarizó y debemos eliminar
las desigualdades que contribuyen a la
violencia contra las personas lgbtq y
más no podemos tolerar el odio en el
debate los ataques contra personas lgbti
pero también el uso de armas Estados
Unidos ha vivido 601 tiroteos en lo que
va de año en un país que tiene más armas
que habitantes y en el que 49.000
personas murieron por heridas de bala en
2021 una cifra récord
se convierte en el primer octógenario en
ser presidente de Estados Unidos este 20
de noviembre de 2022 el mandatario
cumplió 80 años precisamente su avanzada
edad es uno de los factores que ponen en
duda la posibilidad de que se presente a
la reelección en 2024 en los últimos
meses vayan a protagonizado distintos
episodios públicos en los que se le ha
visto extremadamente desorientado o en
que ha tenido lapsus de vocabulario
y vamos a Argentina porque el presidente
Alberto Fernández decretó tres días de
luto nacional por la muerte de un
símbolo de la resistencia contra La
dictadura A los 93 años de edad murió
ebe de buenafinity la presidenta de la
asociación madres de la Plaza de Mayo
quien combatió el régimen de Jorge
Videla tras la desaparición de sus dos
hijos y participó después en la
democratización de Argentina Luis Muñoz
nos acerca más a su figura
por sus hijos y por todos fue el lema de
vida debe de bonafini desde que en 1977
La dictadura Argentina desapareciera a
dos de sus hijos lideró desde entonces
la asociación de Madres de Plaza de Mayo
se manifestaban todos los jueves con un
emblemático pañuelo blanco y el
propósito de encontrar a sus hijos
asesinos hijos de mil puntos
lo cuidamos
nos hablamos de los más profundos de
nuestro corazón La dictadura Argentina
desapareció a más de 30.000 personas la
mayoría de izquierda entre 1976 y 1983
Eve de bonafini paso de ama de casa a un
activista en defensa por los derechos
humanos y no tuvo reparos en enfrentarse
a quien fuera siendo arrestada En
diversas ocasiones yo digo cuando me
llevaron mis hijos me crecieron leones
dentro
bonafini tuvo un gran compromiso
político ante imperialista y cercano a
figuras como Hugo Chávez Evo Morales y
la actual vicepresidenta Argentina
Cristina Fernández de kirchner quien
lamentó su muerte en Twitter
queridísima Eve madre de Plaza de Mayo
símbolo mundial de lucha por los
Derechos Humanos orgullo de la Argentina
Dios te llamó el día de la soberanía
nacional no debe ser casualidad
simplemente Gracias y hasta siempre
tras la caída de la dictadura de Jorge
Videla continuó reivindicando el
enjuiciamiento de los responsables y
trabajó en la recuperación de la
identidad de más de 100 bebés robados
por la dictadura las madres de mayo se
dividieron en dos asociaciones su
organización logró construir casas para
familias empobrecidas fundó una
universidad e impulsó una radio una
imprenta y una web entre sí como persona
soy mucho mejor persona entendí que era
la solidaridad la revolución el amor el
amor al otro
Y eso lo entendí porque me quedaron muy
grabada las palabras de mis hijos
93 años de lucha para Eve quien desde el
dolor de sus entrañas puso su grano de
arena para conseguir un mundo mejor
el brasileño ylán fue elegido como el
nuevo presidente del banco
interamericano de desarrollo con el
apoyo del 80% de la asamblea de
gobernadores del organismo goldman fue
gobernador del Banco Central de Brasil y
jefe del departamento del hemisferio
occidental del fondo monetario
internacional ahora reemplaza al frente
del bit al estadounidense de origen
cubano Mauricio claver carone expulsado
de la entidad Por un escándalo amoroso
con una subordinada
y este lunes el gobierno de Colombia y
la guerrilla del eln retoman los
diálogos de paz suspendidos en 2019 bajo
la presidencia de Iván Duque el primer
ciclo de conversaciones será de 20 días
y tendrá lugar en Caracas Venezuela país
garante de las negociaciones Samuel
Salgado nos tiene más detalles
la última guerrilla activa de Colombia
acude a una nueva negociación de paz
este lunes una nueva delegación del
gobierno de Gustavo Petro se reunirá con
los principales líderes del Ln en
Caracas Venezuela este nuevo intento de
diálogo es consecuente con la política
de paz total del presidente Petro la
última vez que el estado colombiano se
había sentado con esta guerrilla fue
durante el período del ex presidente de
derechas Iván Duque pero las
conversaciones se detuvieron luego de un
atentado del Ln contra la escuela de
policía general Santander en Bogotá en
enero 2019 que dejó 22 muertos esta
nueva negociación es distinta de las
otras para empezar a diferencia de todos
los otros intentos de dialogar con el Ln
esta vez Colombia tiene un gobierno de
izquierda y un presidente que fue
guerrillero ese sentido lo que ha
demostrado el presidente Petro es que
esta narrativa queda sin piso porque él
hace 30 años dejó las armas también en
el marco un proceso de negocia de fin de
conflicto con el m-19 y hoy es el
presidente de la república después de
haber participado en cuatro elecciones
presidenciales Petro pidió la fiscalía
suspender las órdenes de captura de 15
guerrilleros que harán parte del equipo
negociador como Pablo Beltrán que ya era
el jefe de la delegación y Pablo Tejada
considerado uno de los principales
ideólogos en la guerrilla el presidente
Gustavo Petro designó como jefe
negociador del equipo de gobierno aoty
Patiño fundador de la extinta guerrilla
del m-19 así como a María José Pizarro
hija de un ex comandante de esa misma
guerrilla la sorpresa entre los
integrantes de la delegación oficial fue
la designación del presidente de la
Federación de ganaderos el derechista
José Félix lafourie casado con una de
las más notorias críticas de Petro desde
los años 90 se han hecho varios intentos
de negociación todos fallidos está por
verse si ahora Un gobierno de izquierda
logra lo que no consiguieron sus
predecesores
y miles de personas conmemoraron este
domingo en las calles de Sao Paulo
Brasil el día de la confianza afro esta
jornada se celebra en honor a la muerte
de zumbidos palmares un esclavo africano
que consiguió escapar de los colonos
portugueses y fundar una comunidad para
personas que lograron liberarse de la
esclavitud desde entonces en esta fecha
se conmemora la lucha por los derechos
de las personas afrodescendientes y se
celebran los aspectos únicos de la
cultura afrobrasileña
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros
[Música]